محكمه عوفر العسكريه الاسرائيليه الافراج
عن الاسير الفلسطيني النائب البرغوثي
وامرت بلقائه على اعتقاله بحكم المؤبد و18
عاما بحجه وجود ملف سري وقال نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني ان البرغوثي البالغه من العمر
65 عاما اعيد اعتقاله عام 2014
واصدرت المحكمه حكما بحقه لمده 30 شهرا
عام 2015 ثم حكم عليه بالمؤبد ويعتبر
البرغوثي صاحب اطول مده اعتقال في تاريخ
الحركه الفلسطينيه الاخيره معنا من امام
سجن عوفر غرب رام الله مراسل الجزيره سمير
ابو شماله ملف سري هو ما يعوقوا اطلاق
اقدم اسير فلسطيني هل هنالك اي معلومات
خلفيات حول هذا الملف وما يقال عنه
يعني بطبيعه الحال هذا الملف السري هو
دائما تتضرع به اجهزه الامن الاسبانيه
وخاصه المخابرات الاسرائيليه التي تقول
بان هناك ملف سري تقدمه للمحكمه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي يبقى يبقي تبقي
سلطات الاحتلال على اعتقال الاسرى
الفلسطينيين وتحديدا في ملف ايضا الاعتقاد
الاداره الذي لا توجه لهم تهمه او محاكمه
للاسرار المعتقلين اداريا بحجر ان هناك
ولكن في هذه القضيه الخاصه بي الاسير
الفلسطيني نقل البرغوثي ايضا هناك
ملف سري قدم الى المحكمه وبالتالي تم
القاء على اعتقاله وعدم الافراج عنه هو
الذي كان من المقرر ان تتخذ جل محكمه عوفر
العسكريه بهذا الخصوص اما بتنفيذ اعتقالها
او الافراج عنها وهو ما كان متوقع عن ايضا
حسب تصريحات وزاره الاسرى الفلسطينيين
التي كانت تتحدث بان هذا القرار هو رفض
المحكمه لانهاء الاعتقال
الاسير البرغوثي هو كان متوقعا في ظل
التبعيه المطلقه للمنظومه القضائيه لاجهزه
الامن الاسرائيلي والمخابرات والامن
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي لم يكن متوقعا ان
تكون اسرائيل تدخل بهذا الاطار وتخرج عن
اطول
اسير فلسطيني قد قضى في سجون الاحتلال
المدع الاطول في مجموعها في الحركه السريه
والتي بلغت 43 عاما والذي دخل العام
الثالث والاربعين قبل ايام قليله وبالتالي
همم الاسير البرغوثي قدر في سجود الاحتلال
34 عاما متواصله همم حيث تنقل في عام 1978
وحكم عليه بالمؤبد وثمانيه عشر عاما
والحكم المؤبد عند الجانب الاسهال
والسلطات الانسانيه بالنسبه للاسرى
الفلسطينيين هو ربما ياخذ الى منحه مدى
الحياه وبالتالي لا توجد هناك مده محدوده
بشكل همم واضح همم الافراج عن الاسير نقل
البرغوت ولكن يبدو ان الملف ايضا هو بنفس
سياسي تخوض فيه اجهزه الامن الاسرائيلي
بعدم ال ال ال الافراج عن هذه الايقونه
التي يطلق عليها في الشارع الفلسطيني وهو
يعتبر من ايقونات الاصفر الذين يقبعون في
سجون الاحتلال البرغوثي الذي يبلغ عمره 65
عاما قد تم الافراج عنه في 2011 في ضمن
صفقه تبادل الاسرى بين حركه حماس وسلطات
الاحتلال الايطالي برعايه المصريين ولكن
اريد اعتقاله في العام 2014
سمير ابو شماله من بمسجن عوفر غرب رام
الله شكرا لك